all right well Jen's first of all I
think you know we deserve to uh have a
toast
Oh noms this morning best picture Wow
very much I'm gonna actually do this I
know if you guys want actually what is
it boy wants to do a toast or sorry I
think it's a bit of you was it it's
maple syrup this is great yeah well
toast into this but yeah it smells nice
ooh that's good yeah lovely thanks guys
this is like phenomenal filmmaking this
this whole picture I couldn't believe
what I was seeing while I was watching
it and I want to know from you guys like
because sometimes as a viewer you'll be
watching for like seems in in what this
is and it's just amazing how you guys
have done it what's the longest take
what was how long was the longest take
did you guys have to do I think the
longest one was nine minutes yeah nine
minutes
it's pretty tough yeah yeah how do you
how do you prepare for the idea like not
screwing up with a 9 minute take like
it's not just like being in a scene and
like doing your earmarks from A to B or
whatever but you're a to B is like from
here to like all the way over there and
there's extras and there's all this
involved yeah we just produced how to
get through it really like I mean if we
tried not to sort rip ourselves up
beforehand with the idea of screwing it
up but you know but sometimes that
happens you know it was um yeah and some
of some of those mistakes as well you
know what is was unplanned has wound up
in the film because it kind of gives it
gives it extra life yeah we rehearsed
for six months as well before we start
showing so after them six months we sort
of unconsciously know sort of rhythm of
a the dialogue would probably be able to
just run for it all right now yeah yeah
so as you know you know in our bones and
blood I mean as far as an actor's
challenge goes where does this rank
because I don't near you is there
dialogue although the sparse hmm you've
got to make sure that every little
detail is correct but you had people on
set making sure that you were doing
the right way right yes yeah yeah but
there was a military adviser called Paul
bidis it was there every day on set and
therefore the training for us to sort of
learn how to be a soldier yeah there was
I think I think it was kind of the
challenge so it became a learning
experience more than a challenge and I
think it was at the the idea of the
final piece other than sort of when we
very first got the role we sort of never
beyond that it was actually a much more
gradual process so it didn't feel too
overwhelming you know this thing of like
how are we gonna get this done it was
just we just built the whole film and
layers and layers and layers yeah how
would Sam like working honest on a set
like how does he prep you what do you
guys talk about before you do you take
what did we talk about well we knew we
knew it we knew it so I think Sam's so
what's amazing about Sam it's one that
he's masterminded all of this but but
I've never worked with or met anyone
who's got such an incredible
understanding of like the architecture
of storytelling in the way that you
build situations and you how and when
you give information to provide a
reaction to the audience or not provide
a reaction to your own to yet to give an
emotional reaction yeah like how you
know yeah how and when you give
information in time not just in terms of
acting so kind of directing us like is
in our acting our acting but also the
way that human Rodgers sussed out the
movement of the camera as well of when
it's practical and when it's kind of
evoke a feeling when it's just observing
us or when we're just small figures in a
greater landscape he's just he just
happened those how to use the tool every
tool at his disposal to tell the story
yeah and when you guys sat down and saw
the film for the first time what was
your initial reaction like after
everything was said and done how did you
feel what did you say to each other it
was really emotional I mean even now I
mean I've seen the film of five times
now the last time we watched it at the
London premiere and even still I mean we
know every single bait of the the film
we know the story obviously we was there
doing it but it still manages to get
and I was sort of surprised I didn't
really realize it during the you know
the filming of it but there's sort of a
hidden message constantly about missing
home and there's a lot of references
from our character about you know his
brother and his mum and I think I think
people will relate to that as well it
was it was really emotional yeah yeah
likewise I I find a very emotional nut
and the thing for me was it made me it
was kind of not necessarily about the
film it made me very clear on who means
most to me in my own life right and I
think that's what the films about it's
the way that these extreme circumstances
are extreme happenings when when you get
stretched physically and emotion they
you it teaches you what you come back to
yeah and I kind of I had that when I
watched the film yeah you know when
you're studying about history and you're
reading text books it's kind of hard I
think when you're younger to put
yourself in the position of the people
that would have been there yeah time
especially you know people that came out
the other end what new sort of
revelations about that time period and
the people that fought at that time
prayer did you guys get from doing this
yeah I mean I obviously knew it the
first world war before making this film
but all I really know was just the
trench warfare yeah but didn't quite
understand you know the age of these men
and our young may was and the amount of
people the loss of life that was lost
and the sacrifice that they'd made yeah
I mean and that's the amazing thing
about the First World War you know if
you're looking into is there's so much
you could look at you could spend your
whole life doing research and it really
is fascinating to look into yeah it's
funny when you mentioned the age just
then it made me think of cutting above
what age I was particularly when I
learnt about it at school but you know
18 20 years old when you're 10 feels
quite adult
ya know when you're 27 you look back at
an 18 year old you go they're babies you
know sort of like so often it's you know
that that's so young to be going to war
yeah and so that was yeah how young a
lot of the soldiers was was very
sobering and
and just physically I guess as you know
we weren't going to war by any means but
to be those sets were so realistic and
the environment was made to try and be
that environment is you do feel
physically you can kind of you can
imagine what those guys would have gone
through it's just that we got to go home
at the end of the day and sure that's
them for four years sometimes how much
of what we're seeing is practical versus
CG effects because there's no like
everything blends together so
beautifully
I think pretty much everything genuinely
I think yeah a couple a couple of couple
of horizons one or two elements but
otherwise everything you see is real you
know those the art department who built
the sets and Dennis Gassner who was our
production designer I mean the work is
incredible for you know everything was
built everything was built from scratch
basically no-man's land and that was and
that was the depth for us as actors that
was part of the joy it's that you just
you just kind of got loose in it and
just existed in it yeah yeah so we
didn't have to really imagine anything
you know how is it how does it feel
having Benedict Cumberbatch to tell you
that five it's you know that's sort of
you've hit the heady heights his dream
come true
you